this morning we're talking about
reopening plans that are in retreat or
at a standstill in much of the country
the new uncertainty over the pandemic
comes as a World Health Organization
warns the worst is yet to come think
about that for a second at least 16
states are halting reopening
even as large crowds are expected to
swarm beaches and businesses for this
upcoming holiday weekend the u.s.
reported more than 41,000 cases
yesterday alone the death rate has not
risen as fast as case numbers but US
officials warned that could change soon
without action Carter Evans is in Santa
Monica California Carter what are
officials there doing to stop the spread
well here in LA County Anthony they are
closing beaches and they've canceled
fourth of July fireworks displays this
comes as news of a record number of
cases in the county daily cases nearly
3,000 at this point health officials
think one out of every 140 Los Angelenos
could be infected with the virus and is
likely spreading it to others without
even knowing it we can't sustain this
rate of increase on positive cases we
just can't health officials in Los
Angeles County are sounding the alarm
they could run out of hospital beds in
just a few weeks hospitalizations in LA
County are up more than 20 percent in
the last two weeks statewide they're up
roughly 43 percent over the same period
now authorities are stepping up
enforcement gatherings with people you
do not live with are not allowed that's
the mayor of Los Angeles reinforcing his
mandate to slow the spread statewide
California ordered seven counties
including Los Angeles to close their
bars while three of the state's largest
counties including San Diego and
Sacramento closed bars voluntarily on
Monday California is one of 32 states
were reporting an increase in their
seven-day average of new coronavirus
cases in nine of those states the rate
of positive tests is more than 10%
including Arizona where on Monday
Governor Doug Ducey closed bars gyms
theaters and water parks for one month
after
weeks of increasing hospitalizations in
new cases at a news conference he was
asked about letting bars reopen in May
did you screw up we're fixing it people
under the age of 44 account for more
than half of all cases in Arizona and
while their risk of serious illness is
low the public health risk remains they
can also share it with mom or dad or
grandma or grandfather which is what
Sheila Kroll things happened after her
15 year old daughter tested positive for
the virus she had been to the malls was
she taking it seriously no she's the
first one that I wear no masks Grohl
tested positive for the virus yesterday
and now she's worried about giving it to
her 74 year old father who has
Alzheimer's and was recently diagnosed
with cancer he comes in here and me
every five minutes I'm just so afraid
he's gonna get it Sheila says at first
she wasn't too worried about the fibers
but now she is urging everyone to wear a
mask and on that note the governors of
Kansas and Oregon now have a statewide
mask mandate as does the City of
Jacksonville Florida and that's where
the Republican convention is going to be
held in August Toni those mandates are
spreading Carter thank you very much